what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for another ghost interview
everyone out there knows that I'm
obsessed with your show Rose
congratulations yet again thank you so
much we're obsessed with you honestly
best interviews we love them
um it brightens my day to hear that I'll
I'll give you my hard-hitting question
that might take away some of that
positive sentiment early on because
apparently my favorite thing to do with
all of you is to kind of like uh like
drum up competition and I love hearing
about how competitive you all are with
games on set so I got a couple questions
about that the first one I want to know
is what is the game that you play on the
set of ghosts that you're the best at
but I also want to know the game that
you play that you're the worst at
um I'll start with the worst uh ping
pong table tennis call it what you like
it's not my strong suit
um I do get quite into it now I took a
while to warm to the table but I am
definitely not winning the competition
we've got a couple of very competitive
ping pong players Brandon Scott Jones
Richard Moriarty Trent O'Donnell
um so we're all just kind of drifting
around in their Shadows the one that I
have I have won like a game of which is
is shows you my sort of prowess in the
game front is Mancala
um which is just that wonderful little
game that I played with Danielle last
year and we both had learned different
rules it is quite
um there's a couple of different
theories about whether
whether you have to stop at the end of
the row when you if you end in the end
of the row or if you can keep going if
there's any stones on the other person's
side there's a few different kind of um
theories that we've disagreed uh on but
we'll see we'll see we'll we'll have
another round this year admittedly I've
not played that game since I was like a
tiny child in Sleepaway Camp but I
guarantee you I still have like my set
in a corner like in a closet somewhere
oh yeah oh yeah no we've got we've got a
set on on the set now and um it's like
one of our prized possessions I love it
if you can introduce a new game to the
set for season three what game would you
bring netball no question uh I don't
know if hair and makeup are gonna love
it because we'll be dripping in sweat
but netball is a New Zealand well it's
not just a New Zealand sport it's a
sport I grew up playing in New Zealand
that I'm very proud of
um typically it was like a women's sport
but you can definitely both play like I
played on social netball teams where
it's men women whoever want to join but
it's like a basketball without the hoop
without the backboard on the hoop and
there's no contact but it's the most
aggressive Sport and you cannot dribble
you can only bounce pass or part chest
pass I just love it I love it so much
and because nobody knows the rules I
feel like I'd have like a decent shot at
being all right at it it's probably a
smart mentality I thought you were gonna
go board game this sounds much more my
speed I I like you know the basketball
type games and I just got a pickleball
set oh yeah there's been a lot of chat
about pickleballs yeah oh so a lot of
people are talking about that now I'm
very intimidated by pickleball though
because folks who play it are are
extremely intense and competitive about
it it would intimidate me being a
newcomer one thing I got in huge trouble
with was um when we all go away to film
The exteriors we go to this location put
Montebello in just outside Montreal
and it's like this giant sleep away camp
feeling like log cabin thing we stay in
and I remember I brought this I filmed
in Romania a lot and I had a Romanian
edition of clue or Cluedo we call it and
I was like oh my God I'm bringing this I
love this game I love this game and I
got everybody all geed up and sitting
around this giant fire and
um Brandon and Rebecca and everybody uh
like really got into it and I'm quite
bad where I just I was really
enthusiastic about the
um that
in like the showing up and starting of
the game but then I just kind of wanted
to chat with everyone and I was very
distracted and unfocused and I don't
remember the rules and to this day
Brandon is like don't you bring them
home from me anywhere again the amount
of times I've brought like a childhood
game to a party and I've completely
forgotten how to play it oh yeah
it's just it's a nice prop I think I
just like it as a prop I will say the
next time I get to see you all in person
I'm going to bring my Bananagrams bag
and I'm gonna make someone who's good at
Scrabble play with me no one will play
with me anymore though because
bag around a lot never played it it's
it's intense if you're good with word
games watch out it is addictive and like
it's it's got like a timed quality that
just gets you like really hyped and
intense okay all right you you're seeing
listening to it now you won't be able to
do it when you see me play it though
it will become a problem you'll see the
worst of us it definitely brings down
is the exact opposite of the quality
that the show emits all the time
um here's a random little question that
came to mind when I was watching uh one
of the latest uh episodes ghost Father
of the Bride so Little Pete has his
handbook and of course if anyone makes
any marks or changes in that handbook he
knows that it's been altered so what is
your version of Little Pete's handbook a
movie a show a book you name it that you
know so so well that if someone changed
even the slightest thing you would catch
on
um I think there's an Australian TV show
called Kath and Kim that I could pretty
much I would know if any single quote
was off I I like the whole thing is they
use the wrong words and it's like don't
cast nasturtiums instead of don't cast
aspersions so if anybody got in any
single one of those jokes wrong I'd be
I'd be a joke police on it okay I like
that my thing is anytime I hear I know
if anybody Alters Jurassic Park but
anytime I hear those dinosaur roars used
in any other movie or show I always know
you borrowed from the Jurassic Sound
Library oh wow yeah it should be a
special note in the credits there I
would appreciate that
um another little silly question so all
the ghosts on the show do this to Sam
but of the bunch which ghost would you
say this is more like Theory like uh you
know off-camera time type thing but
which post would you say ask Sam to do
the most things but then also I want the
ghost that you think asks her for the
least amount of things
I think
um
I think oh that's such a good question I
think uh
Betsy in the cholera pit asks Sam for
the least
very low maintenance ghost
um and I think Sam probably really
appreciates that I'd like to I'd like to
see a little more of that
um goes to ask for the most I think they
would be pretty trivial things a lot of
the time but I think sasabis would ask
for a lot like a lot of smelling a lot
of pizza a lot of like like he's got
that kind of teenage boy quality
sometimes of like oh come on come on
like he's got a little um
uh is is still finding his independence
in some ways in the group and I think he
would need yeah he would need a little
bit of attention there you teed up my
next silly question quite well because
it is if you were a ghost in Woodstone
what food would you be asking Jay to
cook the most so that you could smell it
most often oh probably
um
having just been home in New Zealand in
Australia for the last three months
Marmite on hot vogels toast with a lot
of butter there's just something that
there's just a nostalgic quality
probably particularly but yeah I'd like
some sort of vogels toast lashings of
butter and a little little bit of
marmite
would you mind it's okay too but I'll
take my mind if if it's an afterlife
moment okay I respect that choice here's
one more for you so again you are a
ghost in good in a wood Stone what is
the thing that you ask Sam to do for you
the most
um
oh it would be something to do with
um the plants it would be Garden related
it would be a lot of like like a lot of
weeding I think I think I'd be out there
having a lot being like can you sort
this out that um beautiful those bulbs
are getting dwarfed by some ground cover
can you rip that out it would be a lot
of sort of fine detail weeding work
there's something really like wholesome
and nice about that because at least
you're putting her to work in a way that
serves everyone because there's a nice
Garden there excessive and sort of
trying to control something beyond your
own ability but yeah yeah all right
let's dig into the beginning of the show
I was asking um Richie some of these
questions lately and it made me
interested everybody's Journey with
these particular things but what would
you say is the biggest difference
between how you pictured Sam when you
first accepted the role and who she's
become throughout seasons one and two
um she can be more
she can be more of a liar than I
expected her to be actually
um it's always with good intentions I
think but
um she's able to kind of finagle things
and cover things more to Trader people
please that that part has been
consistent it's always to try to you
know keep somebody happy or make
somebody like her
um but there's a little bit more of
a willingness to tell stories than I
thought she would um which is good
because I you know Sam in lots of ways
is such a do-gooder and she's so
um helpful to so many people and and I
like seeing that she has shortcomings
that are really apparent and
um and watching them catch up with her
and I was talking about this this just
very recently that I
I mean part of what I love about working
in television is you don't really know
who you're playing when you start it's
so exciting that you know you have a few
things you could maybe anchor onto and
there's maybe some character traits they
think are going to be
um consistent-ish but like all of us you
sort of discovered as you go and um and
you kind of find it from the people
around you as well you find it in your
scene partners and in the writing and in
the environment and um and how you play
Within with an ensemble so I've I've
been really enjoying with Sam she's
she's kind of
revealing herself to me more and more as
the show goes on with that in mind
whether it's a scene in season one or
two which scene have you done that you
found redefining the character the most
for you where every scene you shot after
you found yourself referring back to
that particular experience you went
through
um
this this is just what comes to mind
right now is um when uh Sam's old
College buddy comes to visit and we see
how will and this is me thinking of her
lying but thinking of her just there's a
desperation to connect which I knew that
she had but seeing it with a peer with
somebody who she would have gone to
school with I found really
um
like her frustration at somebody else's
success is such a
it's like it's not a very attractive
thing to have but it's a human really
relatable thing to be like man she's
looking at the ways that she's falling
short in her life and I kind of
found her wanting to sort of level her
friend in that experience a
an interesting
sort of Touchstone for me for for me
when I'm thinking about her and and her
willingness then to reflect on it and to
say like oh God it was you know it was
so limiting it's so limited of me to
look at it like that
um it made me love her a lot more to see
that she can can for sure call herself
out for it still kind of indulge in a
little bit with Isaac at the end
um just it just yeah there was something
that I sort of think about quite a lot
when I think about
what why she's trying to do the things
she's trying to do and and how much is
writing on her desire to be liked that's
something that I appreciate about about
the character of most of all is that
every time she crosses the line and lies
or makes any type of mistake there's
always a moment in the episode where she
reflects and very clearly expresses the
lesson she learns and then moves forward
something and try to do right like it's
you know it's um it's a lot more
appealing than than her just getting it
right or you know making
um not being brave enough to take a
chance or or learn something or say she
was wrong I think I think there is a
bravery in Sam and a courage in being
able to face her failures absolutely
um I jumped ahead there with that
question but I did want to ask this
about signing on because it had crossed
my mind recently because I was
revisiting you know your your schedule
the schedule that the show went through
in terms of casting the majority of the
main Ensemble and getting ready to film
uh film the season and then everything
getting shut down and I think think
someone had said there were a couple of
main roles that hadn't been cast until
the last possible second and one of them
was the role of Jay so I'm wondering
when you're that close to production
what has to shift in your mind when you
picture Sam a certain way maybe had
certain expectations for that
relationship and then all of a sudden
you meet and start to work with the
artist who's going to shape that
character and it could potentially
redefine their whole dynamic absolutely
and it should redefine the whole dynamic
and you should be interacting with the
people that you're working with I mean
all of these characters are brought to
life not just by the scene partners that
you have but by an entire team of
designers and
um you know people who need certain
volume levels in order to get the audio
that they need there's just so many
people Reliant
uh so many people we are reliant on to
build a character and I think my
thinking about Miranda Harcourt my whole
approach with acting has always just
been like just sweep your side of the
street do your homework do what you can
do to have her as ready as possible and
have like a scrapbook full of things you
could pull from and ideas and um and
then you have to be flexible on the day
so you have you to me I have to do the
homework in order to be flexible and to
be like great somebody's bringing
something to me that just is completely
different and particularly if it's going
to be in a partnership you know the
person who's playing your husband or
your love interest is is you you don't
want to be rigid in in thinking this was
something else and this is how they
interact that just doesn't serve anybody
um so I I feel like and that happened
with it's not just with you know A love
interest it was there were a number of
pivotal characters that had not been
cast yet so you kind of to be honest I
like that that's the sort of magic
source that comes in at the end that
keeps things really fresh and exciting
is it's a very very variable environment
but it makes me even more want to kind
of think like okay what are some
references I can have who will Who is
what are some moments that happened in
my life last week that I can draw from
if I'm needing to find some frustration
what are the little things that I can
bring so that all of the variable that
is inevitable on the day
um has like gets to sing rather than the
sort of flounder my mind is going in a
million different directions this is
going to be a very convoluted question
but the one thing I was thinking of
there is you know is there anything in
you know that that scrapbook type idea
that you came up with for Sam that
you've yet to utilize that you're hoping
you get to explore in a future season
but uh I'll start I'll start there
before I convolute everything too much
here I think
um
that's a really good question I I don't
think off the top of my head there's not
like one particular relationship I had
with a family member or something that I
feel like I want to unpack one thing I
am curious about I mean she's very nosy
and she's a busy body and I really like
the idea of because she doesn't have her
own family and the ghosts have become
her family and you know Jay's family are
very very important to her I like the
idea of being somebody who's like
absolutely fixated on the genealogy or
the sort of
um the the broader things of somebody
else's life and I quite like
um I sort of experienced that a little
bit where it's you know it's just it's
more a desire to find your identity and
to kind of situate yourself in the world
so maybe something in that realm I would
like to see Sam explore at some point
but
yeah I don't have I don't have like a
particular moment that I can pick out so
that this might be overly specific but
someone recently told me that you know
they like to do certain character work
that you never see or hear about in the
finished product but it's coming up with
little details like you know like is my
character late to things and like what
are their everyday habits that might
seem trivial but are key to shaping the
person that they've become have you ever
thought about any like little thing like
that in Sam oh often but what's
interesting is they'll you'll come up
with as many of those as you can and
talk about being willing to be flexible
like you might just be given something
in a script the next episode that the
writers aren't you know
um they're not mind readers they don't
know that I've come up with some little
bug and sometimes we'll get to
communicate ideas and plant seeds but a
lot of the time you know you're working
with what you get and suddenly you're
like wait I'm the one who's always late
and suddenly she's like waiting outside
for this person this and and you have to
be willing to um roll with that the the
contrary sides of what you're building
as well and be and ignore it's a group
effort it's a collaboration but no I
think there have been some like I really
like that Sam in my mind is really not a
good singer or a dancer um and they're
like she clearly wanted to be in theater
um you know she did some drama at high
school and was very passionate and gets
her chance to play flower in the in this
show that shoots at their house and I
think it's like um It's Curious to me
yeah that she's
she's very talented in other Realms but
that was not her calling it was what was
it those two and cooking yeah oh and
cooking yeah she's not a good cookie
you know honestly it feels like uh the
show is describing all of my personal
flaws I very much relate to this and I
think she should embrace those
weaknesses exactly doordash and there's
Jay yeah and I feel like she'll you know
who who knows maybe she's an incredible
um like she's like a calculator like she
can work out sums in her head super fast
or something I don't know there's lots
that we'll hopefully discover
um and I do love building in those
little details and quirks but again it
is interesting you've got to sort of
balance that with being flexible and
being willing to to roll with whatever
suits the greatest story because it's
not Sam's story it's the show it's a
beautiful story about a an unexpected
family together too it fills my heart
um I wanted to ask you a question about
just the the production of it all and
how you film this show because you have
one of the hardest jobs on that set
because you can interact with the ghosts
and you have to interact with the living
characters as well so if you could go
back to day one of filming and give
yourself one piece of advice for for you
know navigating and working with that
challenging type of shoe what would you
do what would you say it's just about
like
sustaining yourself like for me this job
is about sustaining energy from the
beginning to the end and making sure
like I've gotten better at that in my
career I think I used to kind of want to
give everything out the gate and you do
sort of blow your load a bit and like
it's it's hard to you know for me
little things but like drinking a ton of
coffee in the morning and having like
that rush and then the crash it's it's
you really have to get it's a marathon
um you have to get better at pacing
yourself so food like when I'm playing
scenes with and without the ghosts all
the ghosts leave and they're fantastic
I'll cast are so generous they almost
always try to stick around to do the
lines off but they're from another room
and the energy levels uh that cannot be
the same so I'm trying to map out where
they are and I really have to be
reacting it's like doing green screen
work it's like reacting to you know a
tennis ball on a stick kind of
um energy and you know and that's not
too discredit they really are very
generous but just the the logistics of
actually trying to put people in a space
make it quite challenging to do that so
I think yeah just just pacing myself
um
and
yeah yeah coffee is a big one I've quit
caffeine recently if you can tell God
it's hell with caffeine well I've I've
for now I'm I'm trying and I've been one
month without coffee and
um I'm just chunking decaf and I do wake
up with a little bit more energy in the
morning it's strange so is is
decaf the alternative yep okay all right
I feel like you're you're somewhat
inspiring me but I'm also terrified to
me next year and I'll be way back on the
coffee what was I thinking so
I'll stick with my coffee for maybe a
little while longer until I try that
um going back to the whole ensemble here
I wanted to I wanted to go I think it
might have been from your deadline
contenders interview actually there was
a quote from the Joe's in there that
kind of really caught my ear they were
talking a little bit about how with all
of the characters the other characters
when they interact with different people
bring out news sides in them and in
particular they use Sam as an example
saying you know she's a different person
with Nigel than she is with heady and so
on and so on so I don't know if you want
to give a whole roll call here because
you may that said that yeah that I
remember saying that
um but I because I completely feel that
very strongly is like when you see
different people uh like I mean I can
only say it from Sam's perspective but
who Sam is with socapis where she can be
a little bit more sort of
um comfortable being domineering and
like my little brother I'm going to show
you where you know this is this and
you've got to do that and then she's
somebody really different with like Hedy
where she could be
quite differential to her but also a
little bit combative in a sort of
mother-daughter way
um you know it's just different
different facets it makes the job so fun
when you can open all these different
doors uh I feel like with Asha with
Trevor not Asha Ash is lovely I do that
all the time when I'm talking like to
you guys when I'm talking about your
characters it's just I think it's a real
sign of not being able to detach a
particular actor from a role because
they make it so much their own it's it's
like I have to have an Excel spreadsheet
in my brain at all times with like who
is that person who I know and love and
who are they playing that I'm talking
about and press all the time anyway
um Trevor is you know she's she's
obviously very boundaried with Trevor
and quite sort of
um
restrained and sort of keeps him at
arm's length in some ways but also you
know feel like has compassion and
understands why he is you know loves
that you know he has a good guy origin
story as well and
um there's just different dynamics that
it pulls out and it's the same when you
put any two Gods like Pony and bangs I
love having Isaac and Alberta together
in a scene is just so brilliant or
um thorfin and flower together like it's
that's the stuff that I think is the
magic of the show is these relationships
and and there's just kind of an endless
like equation of of putting them in
different groups together over and over
again and seeing what kind of works and
what comes out best each time so I hope
there's just more and more of that in
season three is there any particular
character of the bunch that you think
Sam would have the most to gain from
spending more time with in season three
where they could add a new quality to
her that she doesn't have yet
um I think Sam I would like to see
salmon flower together is really nice I
think you know flower is such an
interesting character to me and Sheila
does such a beautiful job playing her
where I'm like there is there are so
many layers and just because she doesn't
lead with
um
lead with her World experience and her
life and what she really knows about
things doesn't mean that is not like a
deep wisdom there that we obviously get
these little moments of kind of
witnessing and I really like those
characters I think there's so much
Intrigue and
um so much to be said from like find the
person at the party who's not actually
loud and sort of running their mouth and
who's probably got something really
interesting to say that they just
haven't really vocalized yet there's
something with Sam and her that I would
like to see
um and there's something Sam's got to
learn from her I feel like sign me up
for that I you you could have said
anybody on the show and I would have
been excited about the idea you won't be
able to answer this but I'm going to try
to ask it anyway has there been any talk
about exploring more of Sam's family in
particular what's up with her dad I am
dying to have those answers too no not
that I've heard of yet again I think
there's just so much to service and we
have such a distinct family that we have
in in The Ensemble of the ghosts that um
understandably that just hasn't been
front and center of the narrative but
I'm very curious and and there's
certainly something going on there and
um and I think we've kind of we've said
a lot about it in what we haven't said
too like we've said
a lot about
um you know her desire to connect with
people and to have really loving
consistent relationships so whatever's
gone on there it's there's there's a
reason he wasn't at the family Christmas
you know yeah you you feel it when
you're watching it I'll end I'll end
with these two first I just love the
idea of you know just shedding light on
how you overcome challenges and tough
scenes on set so is there any particular
uh scene in either season that you know
you read it on the page or like how is
this gonna work you had to sit with it
and think about it whether it's
something that's more character specific
to Sam or just what it would take
production wise to pull it off and by
you know mulling it over talking it
through with the Joe's or whatever you
were able to figure out how to tackle it
and it wound up being a great scene
because of it yeah I think um I had a
scene with Rebecca
um where she and hidey are really
butting heads in this episode and and
Hedy talks about sort of her backstory
and we go into a little moment of
flashback and when Rebecca and I had
that scene and was
it just had big turns that happened very
fast you know in a show that has 21
minutes they just have to move through
things that you know as an actor you're
kind of like oh my God would I be ready
to to resolve that that quickly and and
you have to figure it out and it has to
happen for the pace of the show a very I
don't much understand that but
it just requires some kind of deft
shifting and Rebecca is wonderful to
work with
um for that and you kind of find ways of
going between impulse and
um you know making an impulsive quick
shift and then letting something sit and
trying to find the moments you can to to
sort of eke out that process it's that
that was like a tricky thing to film and
I was really happy with the way that we
kind of navigated it in the end and um
you know she's she's great to talk
through things and and figure out uh
figure out sort of there's more than one
way to skin a cat like okay how can we
actually be communicating something very
different to what it what is apparent
um so yeah yeah that was a bit of a
tricky one and I was happy with where we
got to with that I'm endlessly impressed
by how you all do stuff like that how
you resolve things really quick how you
could switch on a dime from Comedy to
drama and back again it's all things
that on paper if I was handed that
script I'm like that's never gonna work
but time and time again you guys crush
it
I know we're so I feel so lucky I feel
like I'm surrounded by just the most
incredibly generous
um kind talented people who all really
appreciate that they have a job that a
lot of people want and we're really
lucky and so yeah most most of the time
you know we are all able to stay
level-headed and and really appreciative
of that so I'm going to end with my new
favorite question to ask because I feel
like you know this is an industry we
have we have Emmys and things like that
where we give each other Awards but I
find that nobody in this industry tells
themselves a good job nearly enough so
can you pinpoint a specific scene in
either season of ghosts that now you
could look back on and say to yourself
you know like I'm really damn proud of
what I did in that moment
um that's very kind uh and confronting
thing to be uh approached with maybe
you know I think
I think the first I think I wasted it
early on I think like in the pilot I
really like
there was a huge jump to try to get to
of you know to go from
actually I'm lying the start of the
second episode it's not in the pilot
it's it's to get from like okay great
what is this thing that can't be real it
can't be real okay it's real and now I
believe it and I'm gonna just address
all of you I felt quite happy with the
way uh that I just sort of was two feet
in Sam was two feet in on
um singling everybody out technically it
was quite a challenging one because we
were shooting with and without ghosts
one of the first times and
um it was very very early in the piece
I think it was like day two or three
back in Montreal
um we were day two or three of the whole
sort of Series pickup in Montreal so
that was like under pressure working
with
um a lot of a lot of variables that felt
good uh that's probably what comes to
mind I love it I could list a million
more for you and for the entire cast
every single every single moment in this
show like I don't know why this happens
because what what I think you've shot
like 40 episodes at this point or or at
least that's what the ticker is up to on
IMDb you would think I would know by now
but every single time there's a beat
that you all just now I'm like how is
the show so damn good like it catches me
off guard every time oh I did love
um Alberta's epis Alberta's descendants
Danielle's work with Ashley and that and
and trying to come up with the the music
was you know it was so fast to try to
arrange and learn and bring to life this
beautiful very touching end of an
episode and those girls are just
phenomenal they they really did knock it
all like we all had Goosebumps on set
like wow their voices together were so
beautiful and that's really hard to do
um at the best of you know in the best
of circumstances let alone when it's
like super rushed and and hectic and
they just delivered magic I thought
another thing you guys have an endless
list of exceptional guest stars and I
can't imagine it's easy to just like pop
in for an episode or two with a group of
people who were there on set together
all the time and it just it feels like
nobody ever like misses a beat when they
do that
yeah we're very lucky to have the the
group that we've had so far have been
phenomenal I could sing the show's
Praises all day long clearly I will say
congratulations thank you for your time
today and I can't wait for the end of
the season but also I can't wait for
season three congratulations on the
pickup thank you so much we really
appreciate it so nice to talk to you